دخلت اليوم اكبر حزمه من العقوبات الغربيه
على النفط الروسيه حيزه تنفيذ وذلك بتحديد
سقف لسعر الخام الروسي عند 60 دولارا
للبرميل الخطوه تهدف بحسب من اتخذها الى
حرمان موسكو من الايرادات التي تستخدمها
لتمويل عمليتها في اوكرانيا لكن كيف تقول
ان تنفيذ القرار على الارض يبدو صعبه
الحظر سيشمل عمليات استيراد النفط المنقول
بحرا والمنتج في روسيا بما في ذلك خدمه
التامين والوساطه واصول النقل لكنه لن
يطبق في حال شراء النفط بسعر السقف المحدد
عند 60 دولارا او اقل السعر المحدد يتم
احتسابه عند تحميل النفط الخام على متن
السفينه حيث لا يتضمن تكلفه النقل والرسوم
في حين انه لن يخضع ايضا ل- المكرر هذا
النفط المكرر لن يخضع للقرار وبدا تنفيذ
القرار فانه لن يسمح لشركات التامين
بتقديم خدماتها الا في حال شحن النفط
الخام تحت السقف المحدد الا ان وكاله
بلومبيرغ اشارت الى ان شركه انجاستراك
انسورانس الروسيه قد تكون احد خيارات
موسقه لتغطيه التامين ورغم ان تركيا
والهند تعترفاني بعقود التامين الروسيه
الا ان الصين لم تفعل ذلك حتى الان الحظر
يطبق فقط على شحنات الخام المنقوله بحرا
كما يستثني القرار بلغاريا اذا يمكنها
مواصله استيراد الخمر الروسي المنقول بحرا
حتى نهايه عام 2014